daily mail says martha's vineyard
declares a humanitarian crisis
over influx of just 50 venezuelan
migrants republicans slam liberal
islands pathetic reaction and ask what
are the thousands arriving in texas
every single day i love this did you
guys see karine jean-pierre's response
where she's like
it's it's a it's a cruel and unusual
thing to send people to martha's
vineyard and i'm like calm down man stop
bragging on martha's vineyard dude
it's actually like
ron desantis i'm kind of jealous like
why does he get to give them a flight to
martha's what about me yeah you know no
for real like
i got to be honest
he could have
just randomly chosen 50 floridians and
been like you're getting a vacation in
martha's vineyard instead the illegal
immigrants are the ones who get this
luxurious uh vacation yeah well look at
the immigrants that go to new york they
get a hotel in uh in times square so i
mean are they really out of time yeah
that's what i believe that they did
originally it was like six hundred
dollars a night
and then they stopped that policy that
was the policy in the first few uh first
few weeks but but it's not a vacation
they're kicking them out if you see the
the government officials from martha's
vineyard they're coming out they're like
these people can't stay here
there's 50 of them they're calling for
federal assistance right now they're
calling in emergency meetings 50 people
how many mansions do they have over
there how many rooms does barack obama
beach front mansion
that by the way somehow can't be
affected by the rising tides he keeps
warning everyone about how in the world
he has so many rooms let him in let him
in the mansions why why aren't they why
are they being so selfish why are they
being so so disgustingly rude christina
pishaw tweeted wow this martha venus
democrat doesn't seem very welcoming or
progressive quote we don't have housing
for 50 immigrants uh don't the obamas
have a 10 bedroom mansion there minimum
half of them yeah
yeah yeah so the obamas have eight rooms
in their house they have seven and a
half bathrooms they have 30 acres on a
little piece of martha's vineyards
that's said to be of martha's vineyard
that's said to be underwater in like
five years according to them it's not me
saying this and i can't you know this
lady who's talking about housing these
people martha's union is really small
they're very small population it's
likely that they don't have housing for
50 people right now but at the same time
you know exactly what you voted for i
think this is brilliant they there's
tons of properties on martha's vineyard
vineyard that are vacant yeah and
they're and their space yeah but there's
houses and they're not all big mansions
some are like one bedroom one bathroom
little cot like little cottages so i get
it those are privately uh you know
privately owned but hey how about this
how about all the rich people you know
you own a 15 million dollar mansion why
don't you you guys pull your resources
together send it to the government so
the government can do what you want them
to do because you guys like helping
migrants right so why don't you pull
your money the government can then buy
some of these houses and start housing
these migrants what's wrong well see the
trolling me loves that they're sending
them there but the pragmatic primetime
99 alex sign which is i'm usually not
like that i don't want to send these
immigrants all the way deep into america
let's send them back to their home on a
first class ticket well so i i said this
too and people pointed out that the
states don't have the international like
authority to deport people i'm sure so
it's like
international relations are negotiated
at the federal level so the state of
texas can't just
send people they i think they could but
i think there's like an
international incident
we literally have an invasion on our
border it's not just people from south
america it's people from russia people
from the middle east that are coming
through every day and it's just from
africa
but it's a sex trafficking it's a drug
trafficking i think they did i think
they took a woman in for a rape kit and
she had semen samples in her from 22
different people and i think the semen
samples only live for like 48 hours or
something so and there's things called
rape trees out there i mean it's
disgusting where you know kids will find
underwear they'll find tampons they'll
find all kinds of stuff that insinuated
that there was some sort of sexual
trauma that happened on that scene so
it's not okay when these these parents
literally use their kids as collateral
to cinnamon coyotes across the board
they need to send the national guard
down to the border and just shut it down
they need the regular army there not
just a national guard
instead of having a base in every other
country we need to put bases on our
border and try to protect our u.s
citizens 108 000 drug overdose deaths
this past year we have a fentanyl crisis
that is killing literal children left
and right day after day that's the cia
that's the same
bringing that one and you talk about the
iran contra which we were trading with
nicaragua guns and then we were bringing
them in and barry seal was flying these
drugs all over kane into the united
states making it crack cocaine and of
course selling it to the poor
communities freeway ricky ross and
that's all done through meanwhile
the news would then run stories where
they would be like on the corner of 63rd
and cicero another super heroine death
and then the next day they'd be like 16
deaths last night after we ran that
report no joke they would run reports
telling people where it happened and
then the addicts would rush there and be
like i want to buy it and then the next
day they'd be like even more dead yeah
just to go back to this topic 50 those
are rookie numbers barack obama during
covet had hundreds of people at his
birthday party at martha's vineyards
bring them all have have obama host them
obama's a big fan favorite of course
bringing people in here kamala harris
also had immigrants show up at her her
doorstep today in washington dc
uh as she was doing interviews saying
that yeah of course the border is very
secure i think i think uh
abbott
and uh uh desantis should send more
planes to mother's vineyard and it's
mostly because it is a beautiful nice
safe wealthy place
the fact that yeah in the hamptons the
fact that they're saying like how dare
you be so cruel like so cruel we sent
these people to one of the wealthiest
places in the country you all can take
care of them they're going to live
better than they they would have lived
anywhere else absolutely and and they're
at the richest place in the world almost
and specifically when you send them to
you to new york the mayor is even saying
it's too dangerous for immigrants to be
inside of new york city because of the
rising violence so so why send them to
new york martha's vineyard it seems
sorry for me well and then have you guys
seen the complaint from mexico city
about the gentrification of all the
wildlife yes isn't that funny how it
works out like that you know i think a
bunch of white people come oh get out of
here they're making stuff rent more
expensive and they're not speaking in
spanish they're speaking english
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of i gotta be
honest like
when these uh uh when these hipster
liberal woke types discover that mexico
city actually wasn't all sepia toned and
it was actually a fairly cool climate
with delicious food and amazing people
all of a sudden they were like i'd
rather be there especially
yeah especially with the remote working
too that's what they said everybody i've
been there so many times i love it down
there real quick how come like how come
every media depiction of mexico is sepia
it's like it's like you've never been
there
well why is it texas's guy on a horse a
mexican sombrero i mean it's always the
stereotype you know yeah i also learned
that mexican food is actually not
mexican food when you go to a mexican
restaurant it's uh tex-mex oh yeah that
makes sense but i think like most people
from mexico realize that they come to
here and they're like what's this
and you know what's a burrito and what
we've seen here you know thomas soul
talked about this a lot but you know
liberals never have to actually live
with the consequences of their actions i
mean that's the reality the far left
they live all hey this doesn't open
border there's not an open border well
all of a sudden what you've seen
governor sanders do is put it right on
no no actually you can you can you can
deal with a little bit of what every
border town whatever every state is
dealing with near the southern border
and make them deal with the consequences
boy they don't like it dude i just i'm
imagining desantis signing off on this
and they're like he's like i got two
planes let's put 50 and they're like
laughing and they're just like look
this is it's insane to me that they're
calling it cruel to the immigrants i
don't think anyone's buying it i think
you're gonna have some working-class
family you know making 50k a year trying
to support their kids and they're like
you think being sent to martha's
vineyard is cruel
tim we won't let novak djokovic come in
and defend his title yeah literally
because he will not get a vaccine that
is the most safe and effective thing
ever i have six vouchers thank you for
creating it i'll miss you dr fauci but
if you are an illegal immigrant we'll
let you come in we'll give you a cell
phone and if you're young enough we'll
give you a social security number and
we'll give you a first-class ticket to
martha's vineyard to go to barack
obama's birthday what do you think
what do you think would happen if they
sent like 300 people
i mean it'd be it's they're already
determining a humanitarian crisis it'd
be apocalyptic
but maybe that's the only way to get the
attention of these uppity wealthy
liberal types i mean obama lives there
maybe the only way to make them finally
do something is to be like we're gonna
put it in your lap yes they have to
suffer the consequences yep of the of
the policies that they are pushing and
they have been allowed to get away with
it for far too long where it's other
americans that suffer the consequences
and they have built themselves an ivory
tower far from it and it's time for that
to stop this is something thomas soul
talks about he talks about it is
dangerous to put people in charge who
pay no consequences when things go wrong
this is exactly what they're saying this
is why i said this is brilliant i kind
of agree with alex hold on let's look at
this no no continue continue
i agree with alex that i don't feel like
we should be pushing them into the
country but at the same time if you
don't hold politicians accountable
they'll just keep doing what they're
doing just put us in the situation what
is this they deserve better than being
left on the streets of dc or being left
in martha's vineyard they deserve
deserve a lot better than that
man
that's yeah leave them on the streets in
texas or new york city just not in our
home so just please get them out of here
i mean
i said that it's like dc or martha's
vineyard yeah she didn't say texas she
didn't say el paso she's in new york
city
yes it's just where we are yeah just get
them away oh i despise these
these people are just so scummy and evil
man
they vote for things that won't because
they won't face the consequences like
you were saying they live in big cities
and they vote to take away the guns from
a dude who lives in bear country they're
like you shouldn't be able to have more
than 10 rounds in your weapon it's like
what if i'm attacked by a bear i don't
care screw you or pigs
the meme was 30 to 50 feral hogs and the
left went nuts laughing they were like
that doesn't happen and then all these
people in the country were like dude
feral hogs are extremely dangerous and
we go on hog shoots because they destroy
your property and they can kill kids
yeah we can take away you when they do
kill kids yeah we can take away your
guns because we've got a dozen armed
security guards that follow us around us
you know encircle us wherever we go but
you know what you guys don't need guns i
mean it's just the hypocrisy
man yeah well and i want to make this
point too and i think it was thomas
jefferson that said this but this is the
problem with democracy is that it's two
wolves and a sheep deciding what's for
dinner so you know what i mean nothing's
ever going to be fair and if you get the
populace on your side we actually don't
even have a populist movement they
always say oh you know the ultra maggot
is more of the populist movement my
point being is that we are not well
we're not represented
correctly by the people in power and i
think that's why we're subjugated to so
much strife and that's where we fight
with each other instead of actually
fixing look at this one this one from
timcast.com governor jb pritzker orders
emergency declaration following a rival
of illegal immigrants from texas mayor
lori lightfoot and texas governor greg
abbott have been exchanging barbed
comments for the last month i love how
they sit back and just gloat voting for
these policies as texas arizona and
other southern border states new mexico
suffer the moment these states say y'all
can share in the bounty for which you
have sown they go emergency oh how could
you do this you're so evil they're
claiming emergencies in illinois in new
york martha's vineyard dc it's pathetic
but you know what
maybe this is the only way the only way
to make a change the only way to get
these people to stop doing it they don't
think that these other states are part
of the us and i think this is exactly in
line with how biden was giving that
speech about how all these mega mega
horrible people are they're like not
part of our our
democracy uses their positions in power
to punish conservatives and those
against them in the country i mean that
is they take it and it is it is a game
of how do we leverage this to punish
those that are against us and this is
what this is what you see hey as long as
it's in texas as long as it's in
oklahoma as long as it's in these red
states great as soon as it gets in our
states it is a
state of emergency yes exactly those
consequences that we've ignored for
decades i say keep it up keep it up keep
it up abbott desantis desantis should
send more planes out 100 because the
other thing too is
aside from the politics of it
if you're getting if florida and texas
are being overwhelmed and they can't
properly care for these people they need
to send them somewhere why so why not
just send them to where these people
voted for it and like they're sanctuary
cities too you know dc to sanctuary city
california sanctuary state right but
here's what i want to point out you know
they're secretly happy about this when
the census comes around i think we're
like what eight years out or something
like that this is going to give them
more congressional seats tim they say
voter id is racist yet they wanted you
to have a freaking vaccine managed to
buy a hot dog at 7-eleven
i mean that's all you need to know of
course everybody they need this
charlotte charlie crist
in uh florida
says that there should be vax mandates
again
of course they love that their love of
that's not racist having to show an id
and a vaccine card to eat spaghetti and
olive garden that's not racist but
having to show an id to vote in election
that is i would love it it felt like the
policy was specifically about hotdogs
7-11 it was just like everything else is
fine but
well we don't know what's in them and
they're probably dirty
because we do have liability here at
7-eleven so we'd prefer if you were uh
vaccinated for it no but but that just
kind of shows you the hypocrisy of this
and i think you're exactly right that
there is some sort of
ulterior motives with the border being i
think i think they're just scumbags i
think they just sit so did you not see
did you not see the messaging they asked
one of the immigrants and the immigrants
thought that the border's open they're
under the impression that it is here's
here's an example they say
we got to go green and you go okay
nuclear power is very very you know uh
there's a lot of energy density in
nuclear and they go oh nuclear is bad
and you're like okay oh come on like
you're telling me there's no solution
and then we gotta stop what we're doing
that makes no sense the policy from
these people that we got to get off
fossil fuels but that we can't use green
technology like nuclear then they want
they say oh we'll do we'll do solar and
wind even though we don't have the
batteries for it they're not offering
you solutions they're offering you
destruction they're offering you
problems yeah but tim this is just that
is just a perfect example of what we're
going through it's called the great
reset and i know there's different
iterations of the great reset but once
they take us off the fossil fuels and
we're on a battery then they can control
every micro micro transaction that you
go through whether starting your car
turning on your cell phone so that's why
they want us so dependent on a greatest
so we have no independence whatsoever
action man uh super chat he said let's
send feral hogs to dem strongholds
well did you see in pennsylvania or
somewhere where there's a limit to the
clips a guy almost got killed by a hog
yeah because he didn't have enough
bullets
italy somewhere yeah or wherever that
was there's a viral video in italy where
a hog charges a guy and he's only
allowed three rounds and they don't stop
the hog yeah it almost gets in poland
recently there was a child that died
because of hogs you know we attacked
them and killed them there's a big story
everywhere so people get pigs are brutal
like i went to uh i went to a county
fair recently
and they have a whole bunch of big fat
pigs lying around and people were like
oh the pigs will kill you they'll eat
you oh yeah you gotta go in there and
you gotta like whack them to get them
away from you and stuff but you fall
down they'll just be like food yeah
now imagine yeah now imagine feral you
know feral hogs running around
before we move on from the immigration
thing and then i'll be quiet for a while
do you guys remember that joe effing
biden sent
770 planes to tallahassee florida in the
dead of night full of illegal immigrants
and now they're talking about desantis
human trafficking uh well biden was
trafficking kids yes literally into like
tennessee into westchester new york
florida and florida yeah the biden and
they're probably still doing it i'm sure
they are so
you look you can't trust the media man
you know we're gonna
we're gonna put i was thinking about
this earlier and i was just thinking
about how the left has become just this
cult of do whatever you're told and then
i thought it was funny because that old
you know pink floyd thing mother should
i trust the government like it used to
be mainstream acceptable to be like you
shouldn't and so then i was like i have
an idea we're making a shirt
and it's uh i probably shouldn't say it
but i'm gonna say it anyway excited
because i think it's funny and it says
mother
it's a little girl asking her mom mother
should i trust the government and
they're outside at 7-eleven and she says
yes and the 7-eleven guy's injecting her
in the arm with the vaccine
i'm like that that pretty much sums up
where we're at my opinion yeah i love
the vaccine oh speaking of orphanages we
didn't mention laura sillsby getting
caught with 20 haitian
uh orphans at the border and uh hillary
clinton bailing her oh yeah what are you
talking about that what's her name laura
silsby that was a big thing
that's fake news you guys that's
debunked that's uh that that's totally
totally debunked uh npr says laura
silsby haitian orphans would be rescuer
serial rule breaker she's a rescuer see
what
hillary good yeah her yeah
what is it she was where they say she
was arrested lauren silsby i think she
was arrested at the haitian border and i
think hillary clinton they raised like
280 million dollars for haiti and i
think they built like 11 houses or
something like that barely that yeah the
whole clinton global initiative was a
money laundering scam operation that of
course was just
the government including ukraine ukraine
donated a bunch of money to the clinton
global initiative it's just a big
mistake uh idaho press newsguard
certified says laura sills be convicted
in haiti but free to go it must be just
one big misunderstanding didn't hillary
clinton give the mining rights to one of
their relatives to mine in haiti in
exchange for for all the benefits that
they got there i interviewed a haitian
that gave me a very passionate speech
about the destruction that the clintons
brought to that country that has just
been robbed and pillaged by the american
ruling class and i think you can still
find it on youtube maybe if you're lucky
we are change haiti but but
uh absolutely mind-boggling how much
politicians have robbed that country
particularly the clintons and just took
everything away from it uh just to add
up to the other points that we were
talking about before there's still
students that have to go through vax
mandates here in the united states that
still have to get their boosters uh
which is absolutely absurd in my opinion
did you did you guys know about this
story the the un-linked color outbreak
was like a huge thing
where i i don't remember the full
details but i remember there's like a
big expose about it where basically
something happened the u.n ended up
contaminating a bunch of water or
something like that they say it was
cholera free until october 2010 when
infected sewage from united nations
peacekeepers sent to the caribbean
nation after devastating earthquake
contaminated a river since then about
ten thousand haitians have died of the
disease which can cause profuse diarrhea
and fluid loss that can kill with ours
more than eight hundred thousand fell
ill
yeah there's a lot of bad stuff that uh
you know if you could die from diarrhea
i'd be dead eight hundred times so now
you can actually maybe you should call a
doctor yeah
maybe i'm a ghost oh that's how we ended
up here
[Laughter]
i wonder about stuff like the silsby
stuff you know because in all
seriousness she was like the story said
she was convicted
and um
like what's going on
like what are they doing
what are they doing luke how far do you
want to go down yeah i mean
what can i say here
like i could go but like i don't know if
you want me to go now like do you want
to listen and uh before we get too
conspiratorial this will be on the
members only segment but all you got to
do is look at r.i.p uh lizzie macbeth uh
the queen and one of her best friends is
a guy named jimmy seville and jimmy
seville is one of the most legendary
evil uh predators there ever was and you
look at her son prince andrew but but my
point being is with jimmy seville is
that he would supposedly take them on a
boat and we got to say this we can only
say some stuff on youtube and do the
most heinous things to children so why
would a evil person want to have access
to a children well i mean it's either
just going to be a cool tutor a mentor a
mentee relationship or you want to
probably violently do something you guys
ever see that uh south park episode
about the super adventure club
is that i think that's what it was
called someone someone google that
super adventure club something like that
or the explorers club i think it's a
south park episode and basically you
think they're like adventurers but
they're actually just a network of
peters that go and rape kids yeah yeah
that's kind of what happened with boy
scouts with a lot of this stuff i mean
well that was a south park episode by
the way that's just you know fiction
fiction is all it is well there's a
saying nobody likes
other kids except for their own so if
you're like a person that wants to be
around kids all day or they're like you
know mentoring them i almost kind of
give a break to coaches because that's a
little different they want to be like
involved in the sports but i feel like
adults that want to be other people
this is what i can't stand like you
don't want to stretch it too far though
no i can't they're not there
that's part of this a similar narrative
where it's like there was a story of a
firefighter who was sitting on a plane
in a window seat and a little girl was
sat next to him and the stores came up
and said you have to move and he was
like excuse me why and they're like
because you can't sit next to this
little girl and he was like why what and
they forced him to move and there's a
bunch of stories like that this idea
that simply because you're an adult who
wants to mentor kids automatically makes
you an evil person yes i don't think
that yeah no i just think it's dangerous
to be like people shouldn't want to be
around kids no we should keep the
creepos and the pito's away from kids
and people should actually be good
stewards to you know the future
generations no and i agree i think we
need more mentor mentee relationships
but i'm just saying pedophiles or
predators figure out ways in order to
ingratiate themselves with kids so they
use gymnastics or they use whatever they
can to get access to kids that's because
they're predators and so that you know
it was when i was a teacher and a coach
i would have kids go hey you know
they'd say something about being a
friend i'm like i'm not your friend i'm
your teacher like i i don't i don't have
kid friends right you know like i have
adult friends but i don't want a 17 year
old friend right like i'm your teacher
i'm your coach there's a relationship
here but that's what this relationship
looks like and that's where and i'm you
know it's terrible
all the different molestation issues
that we have in schools but to your
point
if you are a sexual predator
you want to go work at a school i mean
you're going to go to where the kids are
or disney or i mean that's yes that just
happened recently again right yes you
know disney talks about that yeah they
their security is as they understand
that they have got to be one of the top
places in the world for where a
pedophile would go and it's yeah you
have to protect kids and you have to
know that again if you are look at this
i'm sorry this is one of them hold on
i'm sorry i'm sorry i mean interrupt but
this was 10 hours ago oh my gosh disney
and publix employees among those accused
of wanting to abuse and groom children
yeah so this this guy is is this the one
where the cop is like it wouldn't be a
sting without disney and then he
mentions like another disney employee
was cut look i don't fault disney for
this i think they're kind of bad for a
lot of other reasons i don't blame them
it's that these these creeps these pedos
these predators know kids these are kid
places and that's why they seek out
these jobs also
schools
and that's why it's crazy that when
we're like hey we got to be careful
there's a bunch of these creepy stories
we had a story the other day about a
teacher who got arrested for banging a
high school student we need to be
vigilant because the predators are
trying to get into these schools but you
get banned from twitter for bringing it
up and that's right and that's where
when you talk about these conversations
about sexually inappropriate material
with kids that's exactly what you have
to make sure isn't going on in the
classroom because look how quickly that
turns into grooming look how quickly
that turns into molestation and putting
kids in these positions and so that's
where
we have to hold the line on this i mean
it's it is protection of kids yeah but
you have to understand this is not the
first time that this happened with
disney there there was a number of
disney stings that you could look up and
you could see a plethora of news reports
there's also the franklin cover-up
there's also larry nassar there's also
epstein edwards heath jimmy savile i
think is the biggest one when it comes
to people being in the industry of
allegedly being in children's
entertainment and using that along with
the connections with the royal family to
do just the most god-awful things and
we're talking about beyond hurting
children this guy was believing in some
like satanic entities was doing things
to dead bodies that i can't even take
out of the morgue yeah
family friendly show here so i'm not
going to get into it but but we have to
understand that the fbi when it came to
larry nasser and epstein helped and
aided and embedded this operation all
the way so when you look at the fbi now
targeting school parents who are showing
up at the teacher school boards who are
concerned about this type of activity it
really makes you wonder what really deep
down is happening here right when the
fbi is targeting parents in virginia
as as
it was definitely talking to them right
domestic terrorists yeah i mean and you
know
alex was talking about this earlier
about how coordinated is it i mean you
look at the levels of coordination where
you literally have a national teachers
union
that comes in and asks and the
national school board association asks
for the fbi to investigate parents at
school board meetings and you look at
this and you go okay if we're about
protecting kids and doing what's best
for kids there's no one's going to
protect their kid more than their mom
and dad
and the further that we continue to box
them out the less they can protect be a
part of what they're what's going on
with their kids but the other part of it
is it's it is the complete destruction
of the family unit we want i mean again
as a teacher one of the things we always
limited we wanted more parents involved
we want more parents at parent-teacher
conference we want more parents talking
to you about their kids because it means
that they're going to get that full
support they're going to be supported in
everything that's going on only at
school but at home but yet the left
wants that separation and you've got
extremists and you have folks that are
actually doing it intentionally to get
in with kids and for grooming purposes
well even on blm's uh you know whatever
mission statement it said the
denuclearization that's right the
breakdown of the family yeah but explain
to me this so when they when you do the
standardized tests now they say like a
sixth grader now is that like a first
grade level or something and they're
blaming that on the pandemic which i'm
sure that had a big part of it but are
kids just getting dumber i mean why are
they doing so bad on the standardized
test compared to not that long ago yeah
you know i i the entire system has been
built in a way that doesn't reward
exceptionalism and doesn't reward
student outcomes whether that's
rewarding teachers or whether that's
getting kids more aligned to the
education that best fits their needs and
so what happens is again the national
teachers union
fought to shut down schools and masks
and fought to put to mandate masks
fought for all this nonsense and then we
have it and it plays out and then you
see the disruption and the school system
i mean our education system was already
not performing well and then you have
the disruption which is just further
indicative of the entire problem the
entire problem is you have associations
that are far left that their concern is
not kids it is their adult membership
so guess what every time we can fight to
close down schools they close down
schools the national teachers union
every time they have a reason to shut
down a school a protest i mean i've
always
think about a teacher blocking kids from
going to school
and that was what you saw during the
pandemic but it's indicative of the
policies they advocate for all the time
are not pro-student they're their pro
their associate and their impro teacher
really it's pro their association their
membership to grow them and leverage
them and so the outcomes that you've
seen are because of intentionally and
they're and i'm sorry you got me on a
rant right you team me up
but the other thing is their entire
world view
is
anathema to student performance
if you believe that everybody is a
victim
okay if you believe that because of your
victim status because america is an evil
racist country misogynist i mean pick
every you know every box that they that
they try to check
and you tell kids that from when they're
three years old
to when they're 18
you've built in every excuse to not be
successful not be successful
there's a reason why you know again my
other hat was a coach as a coach you
don't come in and go hey we're going to
get whooped because that team you know
hey they got more money than us their
gym is nicer than us it doesn't matter
you see athletes come out of poverty all
the time and just kick people's butts
because they haven't been told from when
they're three hey
you know actually you know we live in a
bad part of town so you're never going
to be a good athlete that's not at all
what they're told but we do it in
academics because the left has been able
to take it over so they emphasize
victimization excuse making and kids
respond to that they rise to the level
of expectations you put on them and if
you tell them they're victims cool i've
got to get out of jail card for the rest
of my life because i'm a victim but
they'll be really good at dancing when
they're older because you know that's
one thing they're doing
and i don't want to you know bogart the
conversation i don't bogart the blind i
don't want to bogart the show but uh
norm macdonald has a great joke where he
talks about how teachers jobs were
pretty easy because both of his parents
were teachers and how i know these are
going to get mad because you're a
teacher but basically it's like you know
it's like low stakes and that they get
all these holidays and i think that's
kind of where it has maybe people become
teachers because they know it's easy you
know i'm not saying that it's easy to
teach i think it's hard to teach but
it's just kind of like this like a
teacher can almost be an alcoholic like
there's no high stakes for them to
actually teach their kids the curriculum
they're just kind of showing up and
getting a lot of yeah they're they're
the ones that showing their grades they
can say whatever they want yeah i can
feel like everybody was good and the
lockdowns and the mask policies that
they caused had tremendous negative
effects not only on intelligence not
only on cognitive function but also
obesity there are many studies out right
now showing how these deliberate
lockdowns these deliberate maskings when
they weren't even backed by science have
had horrible tremendous negative effects
on the development on children where
even
what's her name lee or lina when on cnn
came out publicly and said um i should
have never told my child to wear masks
because now he has developmental
problems because and i'm living proof
i've gained 45 pounds of ymca kicked me
out for not wearing a mask let me back
in ymca if you're watching this yes i
didn't on preston road in dallas texas
please let me back in
but i don't think you're you're here i
lost i gained the weight because of them
it's all their fault it's nothing to do
with those milkshakes
you're innocent yeah
the milkshakes drink themselves that's
true you're a big booty uh i'm a big
conspiracy theorist
i love it
yeah well that's what we're at i can
blame the pandemic for everything uh uh
but we'll do back to the teachers i'm
just saying i think that like the idea
of like teachers actually caring about
their students they don't care about
that they care more about their social
issues and like teaching these kids that
you know white guilt and uh yadda yadda
yadda yadda yeah we're we're not
championing excellence and outcomes
we're not saying that the goal of
educate these groups are not saying the
goal of education is to get a kid in a
position to get a job that lines up with
their talent with their skill sets so
that they can get the most out of their
life that's not listen to the arguments
we don't feel safe so we don't want
schools to open well we've got all the
science that says that it is safe well
no well we still don't feel safe well if
you don't give us x y or z we're going
to close down the school so i mean
frankly what are you doing
the kids are held hostage in this in
this agreement here with the national
teachers union so we're not going to let
your kids get an education till you give
our association what we want i mean you
just see how
how we flip the whole thing on its head
and if the argument is
what's best for kids and what puts them
in the best spot to be successful
frankly
you want to have good teachers
you want to have folks in the classroom
that are exceptional that are ambitious
that are talented that are that work
well in that environment that solve
complex problems but you know what when
you create a system that says actually
we don't care actually what we want to
do is make sure our association's happy
what you're doing is just setting a
baseline for saying we're just going to
make this as easy as possible rather
than hey we want to find exceptionalism
i want to make sure that people are
being successful because that means that
the kids will be better off
i see some selfies going on yeah just a
little keep going don't distract you
yeah go back to teaching the kids
exceptionalism well i'm trying to
instagram
i'm trying to get that timple clout
don't don't don't really go absolutely
but completely overhauling all in the
system i'm a big fan of the micro
schools uh we had one we have one out
here that i've i've contributed to
the way they do it is your your grade
level is based on where you are
so if you complete the entire math book
then you're done with math yeah can we
even talk about that for something think
about how silly this is
you're in you're in seventh grade well
what if you get through with the seventh
grade material or you're in seventh
grade yeah okay what if you're bad at
math
good at english
45 minutes in math 45 minutes things
well i struggle with english 45 minutes
in english i mean
the way we've set up the entire system
is to not be flexible to not be agile
and are you familiar with like the maker
spaces micro schools where they give
kids like a maker space and say yeah so
oh it's awesome and they go here here's
the deal
you've got to create a project that does
a b or c boom you got three weeks to do
it wow and they can they give them the
materials and go hey here you go and
it's a it's based on the project this is
where again the over standardization of
saying hey you've got to get 36 credits
and you've got to get a physics credit
and you've got to do these 45 things
every week did no no
what do we want what do we want what's
the end game work with the end game of
mine and what you want for kids and
those maker spaces have been just
blowing up you compare that to children
learning about pronouns it's a no it's a
no-brainer there's another article from
nbc news in 2004 that really kind of is
is very eye-opening and kind of hits on
what we're talking about and it's titled
study one in 10 students encounter sex
abuse in school uh this is nbc news
according to research from the
department of education after quote
exhaustive review of research and those
numbers are absolutely crazy in 2004 i
could only imagine what's possibly even
happening right now thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there